I love this movie so much I'd say it's
definitely my favorite in the franchise
out of um outside of the core Trilogy um
so with the physical release coming up
what are you excited and hoping that
fans get out of the second and third
watches of the nun two well first of all
thank you great to uh great to see you
the um I think for fans I I'm excited
for them to just pick up on Easter eggs
there's so much stuff that we have in
here which kind of connects to other
movies connects to the the larger story
um the uh we have some really cool
behind the scenes stuff and then also a
couple deleted scenes that um that
weren't able to to make it into the
Final Cut but there's a lot of stuff in
there I think um I'm excited for people
to see it awesome I'm very excited to
hear that we'll be seeing deleted sceds
I'm can't wait um speaking of as you
mentioned you really started to sort of
stitch together the universe in a way
that hadn't really been done so so far
yet in the franchise and I really
enjoyed that revelation of how Irene and
Lorraine are connected and um can you
talk about what went into creating that
big like final climactic sequence of of
that Revelation and connecting those
threads yeah it's I I I think it's
something that you know fans already
kind of had theories about it it just
seemed a little bit too perfect that you
know two sisters were um were cast in
the same series and you know it it you
know we they we needed a connection and
and there was I think in the original
draft that I got from AAA um it was in
there it was always in there but it was
more as as an Easter Egg and I just
thought that this is
probably it needs to be bigger I think
that because there was already an Easter
egg in the first nun that connects her
to um to Lorraine in on her passport if
you like look at her passport I think
it's in is like her there's I won't get
into to that but you know I was um I was
like this needs to like we need to
really deliver fans like a really clear
announcement and then I also just
thought like I really think that it
needs to land with some emotion I
thought that you know and then that's
where I started developing the the the
mother story and you know these these
movies always have you know the first
Conjuring I mean has the Family theme
that's like the the theme of um of the
family and it's like once you know
everybody's been saved and I think it
really speaks to just you know the
warrants I think it speaks to just the
these all these movies in different ways
deal with family is in different forms
and um and so I just thought that you
know Irene's connection to her mother
which was it was kind of like a
throwaway line in the first movie in the
first nun movie about how her
[Music]
um basically something to the effect of
her dad thought her mom was crazy and I
just thought like that there's something
there I think we got to pull on that
thread we got to we got to pull on the
Lorraine thread and we got to we got to
tie all that up um and and I think that
it really um I think it connected to
people I think that you know just that
that idea of um connection to family was
like you know really worked I think uh
you absolutely absolutely did such a
great job with that um I was going to
ask about how you go about making sure
that you balance that emotional core
with um the right amount of scares and
like Terror in a movie like this when
you're working with um the script
writers and and bringing it all together
yeah I think it's it always starts with
a script and you're always trying to get
you know figure it out there it's I mean
it's an endless process everybody's so
essential I mean I probably the
most everyone plays an essential part I
the you know I think I was really graced
with some amazing actors I think um I
think TAA does some of her best work in
this movie and I'm so proud of it and
it's not it's not honestly anything I
did I just kind of like I think she's
like in this kind of gotten better and
you know with each movie that she's done
I mean she's still so young and so um
you know just just becoming the amazing
actor that she's going to become um but
I just really gave her the room to kind
of to work with it and to dig into it
and and I'm so proud of her I just
thought I feel like a good coach on the
sides you know I'm just like they're
like clapping her on and just you know
supporting her but um I think that's
like really what you know we feel these
emotions and we really feel the story
through the actors and just like um I
think that that was one of the the
biggest keys of of making it work I
completely agree tysa just such a
phenomenal job in this movie as a huge
fan of this franchise I and your
previous work in this franchise um I
know that you pulled off that awesome
credit scene with some footage from The
Conjuring 3 um can you share anything
about going into the credit scene and
what you want fans to take away from it
and tease anything about the possible
future um first of all what's so funny
is up until this junk it I thought I had
fooled everyone I thought that like that
was like it was foot from coning 3 and I
had cut it out it I think we had shown
it to one test audience and beyond that
no one had seen it the only thing and I
realized the way what gave me away is it
was used like one line from Patrick um
was used in like an HBO Max promo and
that's how I was found out but I thought
I was so smart and I thought I fooled
everyone was like no one's going to know
what this is from this is going to be
great um so yes it was from the Third
conr and the reason I put it in there
honestly was because audiences at the
end of the movie I think it was a little
bit too subtle in terms of how does this
connect to the rest of the
chronology and so that was something
that you know as we tested it people
kept on saying is he still possessed
does he get exercised by the warrants
does it like I kept on seeing it and I
was like oh man I don't know what I'm
gonna do oh my God this footage I'm just
going to put that in there it's like a
mid credit and then the studio saw it
and and then they were like oh this is
awesome this is because theygot even had
it and so I was I thought it was such a
win I thought I pulled the wool over
everyone's
eyes internet found me out you
introduced a new cool like Black Phillip
style sort of extension of Valic with
that new monster um can you talk a
little bit about creating that creature
and sort of
evolving what Valic can do in this
universe yeah you know honestly the I
love the Black Phillip it's a crossover
guys you found it we're breaking it it's
a witch Crossover with The Conjuring
Universe where stand no that's that's a
joke um the you know that actually that
monster was already in a Kayla's first
draft I loveed the idea of a goat demon
I was like oh man how do we make this
look right because we hadn't seen any
like real monster it's usually much more
implied in the cont movies but I wanted
to see more of him um I think that that
was something where I was you know I
know Corin drew a lot of inspir
spiration from bramer's Dracula and I
thought I love that movie I'd really
connected with coron as we we talked
about that um and so I went back and I
loved in Bram Stoker's Dracula the I
don't know if you remember or if you've
seen it the the bat creature the bat
creature that like comes out of the
closet is so awesome effects and I was
like oh my God I gotta do that I gotta I
gotta put that type of monster in the
movie and so that was like the main
inspiration and then we just kind of
went from there and and I I I think it
really worked I think that that was
something that I think people really it
was also very surprising I think that
you know we hadn't seen like such like a
monster in that fashion that was very
physical and tactile you know it's
usually was more they tend to be more
demons and I think that that's kind of
what took people by surprise in your
opinion what are the absolute Essentials
of a good scare you know it's so many
different things I'm still figuring it
out I don't
know I think it's you know every
everyone wants to everyone's ready to go
on that ride I think that you know and I
speaking just as an audience member
going to scary movies I think you're
like you're ready it's like being on the
roller coaster you're ready for it to
like the carts to start like click
clacking up that hill and I think that
that is the you know that that process
of just like kind of getting drawn up
and being latched in like I think that
that
is it's it's a rhythm thing you're kind
of drawn into like you were going on the
ride again
and um being able
to announce those moments in ways that
are not too over the top but still you
know draw you in I think that's
essential and just you know playing it
like a roller coaster you know and they
you know I think also great roller
coasters you know it's the Dynamics you
know it's it's never it's not like a
bunch of the same drops it's like it's
not just a bunch of cork screws it's
like it's a combination of things and
and just putting people off guard and I
think that's part of the the magic of it
absolutely I love that
anticipation um
so you're I've really enjoyed watching
your um your direction like evolve over
these like past few like spooky movies
and you're carving out a really good
space if yourself in horror um do you
have any new like horror projects uh
coming up that you can tease or um any
particular horror IP that you would love
to bring to the screen or hopes to come
back to The Conjuring Universe you know
I have a lot of stuff I I don't know if
I can talk about anything at this point
I mean I I love the genre and I also
think that it's you know it's funny
there was a period of time where people
would always ask like oh well when are
you gonna get out of horror or when are
you gonna as if it's something to leave
or there's something that's like you
know there's there's another T of movie
making I'm like horror is like having
such a moment now it is so resilient I
mean theat audiences love it theaters
like love it I mean it's bringing people
back to theaters it's you know postco I
mean this is like bringing people and
like creating the habit of going to the
movies I mean I'm so grateful to be
working in this in this in this genre
and just making making movies and making
theatrical and I I feel very lucky
excellent um thank you so much for
sitting down and chatting with me today
um I can't wait till everyone gets to
see the n two in 4k yeah this is great
thank you so
much